un grand maître peut-il matterer un
autre grand maître en seulement 15 coups
dans une partie classique la réponse est
oui Matthieu cornette l'a fait pour vous
face à Sébastien felleller lors du
championat de France 2022 vous allez
voir la fin est magnifique on a un
gambiame les blancs vont échanger en D5
Mathieu joue fou G5 C6 E3 dame B6 dame
C2 et ici Feller a débroncé une
demi-heure avant de jouer son coup
montrant qu'il était plus dans sa
prépare et il va le payer très cher la
position a l'air très compliquée les
blancs gagnent un mais vont le reperdre
dans la foulée en B2 ils vont même se
faire droquer ça a l'air pas forcément
terrible visuellement avec le roi en D1
pourtant tout est sous contrôle Mathieu
va ensuite jouer fou des3 étendre un
piège diabolique dans lequel Sébastien F
va tomber à pied joint en jouant H6 là
c'est à vous de jouer les blancs font
mat en deux coups bravo j'espère que
vous avez trouvé dame prend E6 superbe
sacrifice de dame pour permettre un math
de boten avec les deux fous qui viennent
punir le roi noir